The particular case,
I'd like us to talk about in more detail
is linear value function approximation.
So that is in particular the case
where our Q function is represented
as a weighted linear combination of
the features that represent the state.
And maybe the state in action,
but we're going to keep
the action separate for now.
>> Okay.
>> So this is how the Q function
can be represented,
if we're doing things linearly.
So we have this set of weights, wai.
And we have a set of features or
at least this function f that maps
states to particular feature values.
And let's say we've got
n different features.
So if we're representing
things linearly,
what we're doing is we're saying
let's sum over all the features for
the current state, the value of that
feature times the weight that is being
used to represent the cube function for
this action.
And just yes, some of it, essentially
take the dot product between this
feature vector and the weight vector.
And it's these parameters, these wa's,
that are actually providing us
the generalization, the ability to make
a prediction to new states because
there's parameters that are shared
between all the different states.
>> Sure, that makes sense.
So it's like in their own network
with nothing nonlinear going on.
>> Yeah, in this particular case it
is exactly a [LAUGH] linear function.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Which you can think of as
being under all that without any
nonlinear and with a single layer.
>> Yeah, and so
in fact you have a whole set of them.
You have a whole set of neural networks
all kind of happening in parallel.
I suppose you could claim that
they're one neural network with
a the non-linearity, which is kind of
some kind of max function or something
that figures out which action you should
take based upon each of the Q(S,a)'s.
And so you really are kind of
learning a neural network.
>> Yeah, I can agree with that.
I mean, we're going to talk a little bit
more about using more general neural
network structures in this setting,
instead of just linear weights.
But the linear weight case is kind
of easier for us to think about.
And there's actually been a tremendous
amount of research on this particular
case because the hope has been that
it's more well-behaved than what we get
with non-linear function approximation.
>> Usually is.
>> Let's think a little bit about what
these weights are actually representing.
>> Okay.
>> One way you can think
about the weight for
a feature is that it gives a kind
of sense of importance for
each of the features in how much they're
contributing to the action's value.
>> Sure, so, if the weight, ai,
is 0, then it doesn't
matter what the feature is.
It doesn't contribute at all.
>> That's right, and so, then,
it completely ignores the feature for
that prediction.
>> And if the weight is a billion,
then it means a lot, probably.
And if it's negative a billion
it also means a lot,
just in the different direction.
>> Right sort of anti-importance.
>> Well, not necessarily, I mean,
the feature depends upon how you
want to interpret the xi
produces a negative number.
And you're actually,
the weight is also negative.
If you're saying that that
feature is really important and
the negativeness just it's kind of
a function of the fact that you want you
want Q values to be higher
if you're going to use them.
>> Okay, all right, I think that's
a good way to think about it.
All right, so
this just kind of makes sense or
you feel like you appreciate the notion
of a linear value function approximator?
>> Yeah, I think so, that makes sense.
You just add up all your features and
weight them appropriately.
>> Cool, all right, so let's kind of
make sure that we understand this.
>> Okay.